hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of Molly no monsters
today we're going to look at how a young
entrepreneur who had it difficult to
keep it up in class and didn't believe
in himself changed his life around and
became one of the wealthiest man in
North America this is a story of truett
Cathy from chick-fil-a and the top three
lessons that you can learn from his
success Samuel truett Cathy is a founder
of chick-fil-a a quick service
restaurant chain based in suburban
Atlanta Georgia when his parents
couldn't pay their bills from his
father's job they began renting out
rooms in their house providing a bed and
two meals to a guest for a dollar a day
at any given time there be as many as
eight guests in the Cathy house that on
top of Cathy's two brothers four sisters
and parents according to cathy grown up
in a boardinghouse introduced me to hard
work and taught me the value of diligent
labor by the time he was eight years old
kathy was already an entrepreneur
chipiya nori could help support his
family he began buying six packs of
coca-cola for 25 cents and selling
individual bottles door-to-door of five
cents each in high school he right
thinkin Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill which
had a profound impact on his life I
wasn't all that bright I had difficulty
keeping up in class and it always
carried with me a bit of an inferiority
complex but I enjoyed my work and I
enjoyed the rewards of working as I read
mr. Hills book I realized I could do
anything I wanted if I wanted it badly
enough his words motivated me and showed
me that I live in a do-it-yourself world
was just over ten thousand dollars of
his own money and the bank's money Cathy
opened up his first restaurant in 1946
today his chick-fil-a restaurant chain
has over 1500 locations and Cathy's net
worth is over 1.5 billion dollars making
him one of the richest people in North
America
by believing in himself and by working
hard happy became one of the wealthiest
men in North America to help you take
your business to new riches here are
three action items that you can learn
from chillicothe action Adam number one
lead from the front your business will
only be as strong as the people you have
helping you if you want them to perform
and be motivated than you need to be a
source of inspiration and lead them
after a particularly rough year in 1974
when inflation rates rose unexpectedly
chick-fil-a was hit hard in the
pocketbook they had to spend more money
on advertising to track people into the
restaurants not wanting his operators to
lose their shirts Cathy decided he would
cover the unexpected increase in costs
he took the hit so they wouldn't have to
according to kathy i didn't take a
salary that year because i didn't want
our employees to take pay cuts I
struggled with this but I was determined
not to lose sleep over it too many CEOs
are leaving sinking ships they should be
the last ones to leave the company if
some people are losing money everybody
should lose money not just the
stockholders action item number to build
a culture if you're really clear about
the type of company that you want to
build and the type of people that you
want to hire then it will be much easier
to attract people to you who believe in
your vision there's no right or wrong
culture but it's important that you
build one that people can rally behind
if you really want to accelerate your
business growth Cathy doesn't believe
that businesses should be open seven
days per week he built a culture around
working hard for six days and then
having one day off to spend with your
family and for your spiritual well-being
as a result he attracts people who
believe in that culture and strengthen
it according to cathy why do we closed
on Sunday well it started back in
nineteen forty six when I opened my
first restaurant after the first week I
determined that if it took seven days a
week to make a living I should be in
some other business we find closing on
Sunday attracts those people who give
attention to spiritual growth and our
family oriented the fact that we have
sunday closing helps attract quality
employees
action Adam number three keep your
priorities in order as entrepreneurs we
often don't do a great job of managing
our lives we work too hard eat bad food
don't look after our bodies neglect
those around us all in the name of
building our businesses if that's you it
might be time to reconsider where your
priorities are when Kathy with 38 years
old who is diagnosed with colon cancer
he thought his life as he knew it was
over it wasn't but the experience did
force Kathy to re-examine his principles
according to kathy i think i'd like to
be remembered as one who kept my
priorities in the right order we live in
a changing world but we need to be
reminded that the most important things
will not change if we keep our
priorities in the proper order
so remember lead from the front build a
culture and keep your priorities in
order the finish of this video I wanted
to share one of my favorite true stories
about truett Cathy and some of his
basketball as chick-fil-a group Cathy
knew he needed a new tactic to attract
more customers this was one Cathy first
introduced advertising hiring a company
to give chick-fil-a a public face the
result large billboards showing cows
that urge people to eat more chicken it
was a humorous slogan and it worked
thank you for joining me for another
edition of all the Masters I hope you
enjoyed if you like the video please
give it a thumbs up I'd also love to
hear your thoughts and comments if you
want to leave it below and stay tuned
for the next episode
you